firefighters battling the deadliest
wildfires in California history say they
finally turned a corner at least 40
people have been killed since the fires
began more than one week ago around 5700
homes and businesses are destroyed the
Sonoma County Sheriff says 140 people
are reported missing that could be in
part because of communication problems
evacuation orders are still in effect
for around 75 thousand people
15 large fires are burning across the
Strait up across the state Mireya
Villarreal is in Santa Rosa Maria good
morning well good morning some good news
here 75 thousand evacuation orders were
lifted yesterday and now many people are
returning home or what's left of them
for the first time since the fires broke
out and while firefighters are warning
the danger is still here they are
confident the worst is behind them a
week ago this started as a nightmare and
the day we've dreamed of has arrived
optimism is growing for firefighters as
they be back the flames still burning
across Northern California we're turning
the corner you're seeing those
containment levels coming up things feel
good in our gut as firefighters but
they're not in the clear yet on Saturday
night this home in Sonoma County burned
down nearly a week after the fires first
broke out it's gone it's completely
victims like Christina shot are now
returning to some of the hardest hit
neighborhoods to take stock of what's
left it was a really bad everybody would
come in and skating outside this is a
one stop shop for the beginning of
what's going to be a longer
fimA represented a victor Inge says that
process can start at local assistance
centers like this one in Santa Rosa
people hoping to rebuild can apply for
federal disaster assistance canceled
utilities and even visit the DMV for
families that have lost everything this
is where they are finding a fresh start
the outpour of all the help and caring
and patience is just amazing the power
Gas and Electric Company right now is
working to restore all of the power to
this area in the fire zone by tonight
and while the cause of the fire is still
under investigation we do know the state
has ordered PG&E to keep all of the
evidence that could be related to these
fires Charlie thanks Maria